lui est venue pierre messmer ancien
premier ministre ancien officier de la
france libre et est cité par la défense
il a tenu à être présent à la barre je
ne suis pas de ceux qui se font faire
des certificats médicaux de complaisance
ou fille répond par un écrit aussi
vagues que possible mon témoignage
devait servir les arguments de la
défense
mais l'ancien compagnon de la libération
va appuyer sa déposition sur les
conclusions du jury d'honneur qui en
six mois après les révélations de la
faire par le canard enchaîné a rendu un
avis mitigé
oui maurice papon a eu un passé de
résistant mais il aurait dû démissionner
dès juillet 1942 pire messmer à la barre
a déposé dans le même sens
seize ans après le dernier survivant de
ce jury d'honneur n'a pas varié certains
essayent de laisser croire que le jury
d'honneur avait absurde pas pour cette
absolument faux le jury d'honneur a été
divisé on a discuté très longtemps mais
le riz d'honneur a été unanime pour dire
que là se parant avait commis des fautes
contre l'honneur et qu'il aurait dû
donner sa démission des cadres en deux
mais qu' il avait prouvé qu'il avait une
carte de régis temps on n'a jamais su
comment on enfin ils avaient une carte
de registre
le procès reprend à 13h30 à la barre
aujourd'hui un autre ancien premier
ministre raymond barre